and to introduce away three deleted
scenes from various seasons of Game of
Thrones that could have given us a
better insight in certain characters
while some could have also foreshadow
the upcoming events that were of great
importance let's start with a deleted
scene from the second episode of the
fourth season as we all remember Tyrion
fearing for Shea's safety decided to
send her away while insulting her in the
process sin ended with Tyrion telling
shade that she will have a comfortable
life in Pentos and that Bronn will
escort her to her ship a bit later
Tyrion s bran if she was gone on which
brown shirt him that she boarded the
ship and the ship sailed away as well as
assuring Tyrion that no one had been
following him while escorting her four
episodes later during the trial against
Tyrion for the murder of King Joffrey
she appeared as the final witness of the
crown and falsely accused Tyrion of
kidnapping her and forcing her to seduce
him whereupon she also falsely accused
sense of desiring revenge and forcing
Tyrion into cooperating by denying him
entrance into her bed well we just as
Tyrion were shocked and surprised by
Shae even appearing as the witness
during the trial against Tyrion not to
mention by her being the witness of the
crown and by falsely accusing Tyrion and
sense of her crimes they did not commit
it all wouldn't have been that
surprising if the second episode of the
fourth season had contained this scene
that I'm going to show you right now in
this deleted scene bran comforts Shae
after Tyrion told her that he is sending
her to Pentos as well as insulted her
multiple times in process and it
provides some setup for Shea's betrayal
or Tyrion later in the season these
people even the good ones are uses as
they please and when we're no longer any
use spit us out find someone else
they're like look at me you ever seen an
old cell sort no such thing
every day I'm a little bit slower the
kids coming up and all manner of madness
with their blades moves I never dreamt
of we have to adapt to circumstances
who's one saying learn some new tricks
this deleted scene for shadows shades
betrayal / Tyrion and if the scene had
taken place on the show we most
certainly wouldn't have been that
surprised when we saw che appearing four
episodes later as the final witness of
the crown Brown told the shade that she
needs to adapt to circumstances and
learn some new tricks and four episodes
later resolved that she adapted the
circumstances and decided to betray
Tyrion decided to be the witness of the
crown against both Tyrion and Sansa the
following deleted scene provides us once
again a fact that time Lannister beside
being known as a ruthless man-made
calculating behavior was also extremely
intelligent as in this scene he could
see through grand maesters game the
acting hands decree surprising perhaps
in the black cells you truly found your
level I'm I only want to see through
this performance is it possible that so
many could be so stupid for so long in
public by cell pretended to be clumsy
senile and possessing a constant stammer
while in private or in the presence of
time Lannister as we can see in the
scene I shall show that he was actually
feigning the stammerer in an attempt of
being unpredictable in this clip I saw
also admits the timing that he's
ambitious and simply once thought less
his opponents believing it myself and
why do you bother so many flowers my
lord he's wanting to grow the tallest
bloom the brightest
then one by one sooner or later they all
get plucked I don't want to be the
tallest or the brightest I only want to
remain in the garden until my time comes
to return to the dirt well thank you for
your poetic candor but I still don't see
why I should let you back on my counsel
the King was canceled my lord I could
have you returned to the dirt if you
liked this deleted seem disapproving
once again how intelligent I'm Leinster
was it could have also her share of the
fall of house Tully if the scene had
taken place on a show as I already said
in one of my recently published videos
unlike most of other TV shows Game of
Thrones is a show that has many times
foreshadowed main events for in advance
mostly because showrunners David Benioff
and Dan Weiss have a show based on a
book series and show is not written on
season by season basis but Lynn Starks
death was foreshadowed in the very first
episode of the series and valve timing
Lannisters death was foreshadowed in
season 4 which are only two examples
this deleted scene would have her share
of the fall of house Tully as the Talley
schedule is a silver trout and a red and
blue background if you would like to
hear more details about how Ned Stark's
death as well as timing Lannister's
death were foreshadowed feel free to
check out my video regarding the
three-headed dragon theory next
delirious scene is from the second
season while it wouldn't have her
shadowed anything it would have given as
an answer a question that bother us in
that particular episode which was who
betrayed an heiress and stole the nurses
dragons I'm sure most of us remember
while the nearest cent sorrows and EXO's
had a meeting with the spice King her
dragons were stolen from xaro's home
half of the nurses men had been brutally
killed a the nurses handmaiden died as
well
while the Reardon heirs the second
handmaiden was missing in the following
episodes are hosted the Council of the
thirteen so the nurse could appeal to
them for aid which was only Cyrus
pretends to hold a council in his home
during the meeting Patti revealed that
he was responsible and Zyra announced
his intention to seize control of the
city
whereupon the Warlock use his magic to
kill the rest of the thirteen
after retrieving dragons from the house
of the undying Daenerys returned to
their home to confront him for his
treachery and found him in
Vittoria which revealed that Doria
wasn't kidnapped or killed but rather
betrayed an heiress and her dragons to
the conspirators however while it took
two episodes to find out which people
betrayed the nearest there's a deleted
scene that would have sold almost the
whole mystery in the very beginning as
it would have revealed that siren Duryea
betrayed an heiress here's the clip
a trader from Qarth told me this comes
with a silk cord around the link tied
very he told me is the danger now beside
revealing the Ria's betrayal over
Daenerys sent her murder over arey
this deleted scene would have also
revealed Zara's betrayal in the very
beginning since as we can hear maria
starts her sentence with a trader from
Qarth told me early in playing on zara
since he was a powerful merchant prince
of the great city of Qarth the fort and
alas deleted scene he will be introduced
today with is from season six and it
provides us quite an interesting
conversation between Olenna Tyrell and
her son mace actually she sent you to
the iron bank to negotiate you must
master a coin it seemed only natural
Cersei Lannister sent you to brought us
to get you out of her way and she sent
the bloody Kingsguard to make certain
you stayed there so out of her way you
stayed eating drinking singing while
your own children were being rounded up
by which is an entirely unfair
accusation look me in the eye and tell
me there was no singing
well it won't happen again Kevan
Lannister has asked me to attend into
small council meetings yes so does this
mean you'll be the Marshall coin mark it
means I am the mistress of getting my
grandchildren out of bloody prison we
want the same thing they're my children
and I'd fear for them every day and
every night and we leave this miserable
place and if the sparrows and
Lannister's rip each other to pieces
the queen of thorns reveals to her son
that Cersei did not ask him to personal
travel to Braavos to negotiate better
terms with the armed bank because her
she thought he was capable of doing such
things but rather to get him out of her
way so he couldn't deal with the
situation Margaery and Lawrence's
imprisonment this deleted scene once
again proves that Elena's most prominent
traits are her sharp with high cunning
and intelligence while the same could
not be told for her son who wasn't the
most intelligent man however it also
shows us once again that Elena loved her
family dearly especially her
grandchildren following the death of her
family the Queen of thorns is left as a
sole survivor and ruler of house Tyrell
and it's most certainly going to be
interesting to see a Lannister role in
seventh season in the season 6 finale
she made it clear that since her entire
future has been robbed from her she
doesn't care about survival but is ready
willing to die if it means destroying
Cersei however it does seem that Elena
will not last long in the seventh season
which for more details you can check out
in my video regarding the deaths of main
characters in the upcoming season before
I wrap up this video let me also
introduce you with a new promotional
photo that has been published by the
time yesterday in this photo we can see
the nearest cent her crew in a rowboat
arriving at Dragonstone well in the
background we can also know this jørgen
with Syrian and Rey Gulf flying over a
huge fleet of ships this photo is taken
from a scene that will take place in the
season premiere and as always let me
know your opinion about all of this in
the comment section down below